naomi und robbie van dyk lernen wieder
das turnen zu lieben
viele jahre lang war ihre liebe zu
diesem sport verschwunden
im alter von zehn jahren bereit für
große erfolge zogen die zwillinge in ein
elite trainingszentrum in der nähe von
köln
doch als ihre leistungen nachließen
wurden sie von ihrem trainer als fett
und faul beschimpft das schlimmste fand
ich eigentlich dass er dann teilweise
auch bei wettkämpfen gesagt hat nein ich
fahre nicht mit weil ihr blamiert milch
und das ist eben wenn man 14 jahre alt
ist oder 15 braucht man finde ich ein
trainer der immer hinter einem steht
egal wie schlecht man tun bei jedem
wettkampf wo wir dann hingefahren sind
um dann entweder kurz vor dem wettkampf
zu sagen er ist zu schwer oder blamiert
milch bei einer barren übung wurden nach
eigenen angaben absichtlich auf den kopf
fallen gelassen um ihr eine lektion zu
erteilen
er hat mich vorher zwei drei mal
aufgefordert ich soll tiefer runter
gehen tiefer runter gehen aber ich
wusste ja dass er mich ähnlich hält
deswegen bin ich tiefer runter gegangen
und dann hat deshalb beim dritt mann bin
ich lieber runter gegangen hat er
losgelassen und dann war es so nach dem
motto ja sicher sie beschwerten sich
beim regionalen turnverband dort habe
man sie nicht ernst genommen oder ihnen
nicht geglaubt und ihnen das gefühl
gegeben sie seien das problem also ich
weiß noch dass ich mit vierzehn dann
auch einfach kein ton anzug mehr
anziehen wollte und immer als gedacht
das ist ja alles an mir ist falsch also
mein aussehen wo ich herkomme wie ich
tun wie ich rede wie ich bin also das
hat einfach so meine persönlichkeit
schon verletzt der rheinische turnerbund
zeigte sich in einer stellungnahme zitat
überrascht von den vorwürfen und ergänzt
der rtb nimmt die erhobenen vorwürfe
sehr ernst und wird die sachverhalte
schnellstmöglich aufklären
damals wurde ruby und harrie van dyk
gesagt sie sollten sich entweder mit dem
trainer abfinden den sport aufgeben oder
was sie schließlich taten in das elite
trainingszentrum nach chemnitz wechseln
vor einigen wochen wurden probleme dort
vom magazin der spiegel aufgedeckt mehr
als ein dutzend anderer turnerinnen warf
der chemnitzer chef trainerin gabriele
friese vor sie gemobbt und trotz
verletzungen zum training gezwungen zu
haben
ruby und nami van dyk sagen dass
schmerzmittel und injektionen ohne
rezept frei verteilt wurden und ohne das
wissen der eltern aber die zwillinge
hatten wegen ihrer vorgeschichte das
gefühl nichts dagegen sagen zu können
weil halt immer hieß ihr seid zu lästig
und ihr seid das problem hieß es dann
also wollten wir einfach nicht lästig
sein als wir wollten einfach zeigen dass
wir eben eigentlich fleißig sind und
dass wir selber zu hören gerne touren
möchten und haben auch deswegen auch
viele sachen gar nicht erst angesprochen
das hatte seinen preis robbie van dyk
musste ihre ständigen rückenschmerzen
ignorieren
eine trainerin sagte ihr dass sein nur
die nerven vor dem wettkampf dann gab es
noch eine neben trainerin in chemnitz
und die hat mir eben häufig gesagt dass
verein bildung dann rückenschmerzen und
ob ich den unterschied zwischen
muskelkater und richtigen schmerzen
überhaupt kennen würde
und das ging eben anderthalb jahre lang
so und dann habe ich das irgendwann auch
geglaubt dass es natürlich nur
einbildung ist aber es war nicht nur
einbildung ruby der der zugang zu ihren
mrt bildern verwehrt wurde brauchte
schließlich eine operation trainerin
freese die während der prüfung der
vorwürfe suspendiert ist hat alle
anschuldigungen als haltlos bezeichnet
und sagt dass sie nie grenzen
überschritten habe
dieses klare dementi hat die zwillinge
dazu veranlasst ihre geschichte zu
erzählen wir können auf jeden fall
bestätigen dass es nicht haltlose
vorwürfe sind die die mädchen
vorgebracht haben also 23 von dem
mädchen waren ja auch gleichzeitig mit
uns damals in chemnitz und waren ja
quasi zeugen dann dabei wie die anderen
an schlecht behandelt wurden zum
beispiel und da können wir einfach sagen
dass es nicht haltlos war
aktuell treten ruby und naomi van dyk
nur national an und träumen nicht mehr
vom internationalen erfolg aber
zumindest können sie jetzt wieder mit
einem lächeln auf dem gesicht turnen